did I like seeing rare things man they
used to have I remember they had
somebody called an art podcast and they
said they'd never seen a black little
person before like a black yeah
and they had one in our town dude and he
had these dreads right this dude named
uh no Dante right no Dante yeah and he
had these dreads bro and they were heat
they were so long he would trip
over him when he was running bro but he
was a G dude yeah and he would
play basketball but he would like he
would kind of cheat a little bit cuz it
was almost like sauce sometimes you'd
almost catch him playing soccer but he
was so fast you could barely see it
Thank You kiddie with his feet but since
he was sure you'd let it slide yeah
you'd let it slide
now where I come from really no no no
can't have that yeah man people I think
he was like I'm town mascot people loved
him and I don't know I love how you take
calls and you're like we had a brother
in quints a dent in our town no three
story best brother name I've ever heard
coincidence I've never seen the mom that
name there her two kids lavash of the
dryer it's real but one of my favorites
was oh uh this lady in my town named her
kid no Dante she goes because I knew he
was gonna be bad I was just gonna call
him Dante but I knew he was gonna be bad
so I called him no Dante so when I say
his name he already know you're not
supposed to be doing it no great
brilliant really no Danny I would name
all my kids that know Susie and this
draw the smallest head did and her hair
made it look like her head was
regular-sized but then it's tiny but if
you would start like kissing her and
touching my grabbing her head or
anything could almost yeah you could
almost you could touch like the back of
like the base of her neck like that
little part that end in in the back of
her neck and then all the way in between
the front of her eyes just a little tiny
mouse he thought and then regular body
regular body he was like is like the
movie Beetlejuice where they sprinkle
you man she had that regular body but
she had that uh yes she had that real
just I don't know what kind of head it
was just yeah tiny head tiny brain did
you ever really been with a girl when
you you feel their head you can feel the
tracks like oh yeah
now girls do tracks almost yeah it's
almost even white girls it's like a
weave but they put it in there
I like the traps I like the tracks you
know you feel like you can feel around
in there and maybe find a bag of dope or
something you know I don't like it you
don't know yeah leave that here Z
Lorant the toughest man I've
ever met was this woman Kizzy Lorant my
god ready to go jump over a volleyball
net dude oh yeah yeah I mean she was
tough as hell and she has a son now
actually who's a dick he just guy he's
playing College he might be playing at
Georgia or something but he was a beast
a beast he was like the top running back
in uh in Louisiana last year
laughing Fernet no Broomfield is his
name no he's still in he just got a high
submit a gay man because we both bus
tables that uh could have been Italian
food I remember what kind of food it was
vague Bistro vague Bistro it was it was
and uh and then what happened was he
ended up having drugs he was Italian he
look like don flamenco from Mike Tyson's
punch-out
can you bring our pitcher Don flamenco
was that the rose in the mouth yeah that
guy that guy oh yeah bring him up right
there
yeah the Roses with one of the right one
more he look just like him right okay
and he was homosexual and he was a
busboy as well even though he's an adult
and he got me into doing steroids and we
still run marijuana back and forth
across the causeway bridge right pounds
of marijuana and he actually did a bunch
of pills later and died drove into an
embankment but one night I'm over at his
house I know one item over his house
Princess Diana died I knew Princess
Diana was dead really
I thought Princess Diana was like the
mayor of our town or something like I
didn't really know what was going on
okay you know yeah
we're sitting over his house Highness of
marijuana and he started crying and
saying Princess Diana died and he had
just made us some chicken me and him and
corn and we're sitting there just having
a meal I don't know who Prince Dinah was
I was high as and then he said he
had steroids and then next couple months
we used to go I think he loved me honest
we never made out or anything I was a 16
Kevin Spacey move on you're nothing like
no see if I hold you down deal he just
always took care of me do you think
there was like kind of like almost like
he was probably about 30 it was 30 year
old boy you were how old at the time
that's why 15 or 16 so he loved you he
loved man but he in a weird way too
though yeah but just like in it but he
was also the toughest dude in the
register get like dude is no way he
would knock anybody in around he might
even knock this girl out oh he's tough
guy I mean he was just a tough like
tough soccer dude he'll suck your dick
and then knock you the out
did you ever see him like dudes
or anything since he was punching suck
no he I think he might know he would
just accuse everybody of being gay all
the time
[Music]
no he live with my brother though I said
to my brother they both need a roommate
and they were good friends he was a good
friend to him he took care of me just he
was just like a buddy like I never had
like kind of like a older brother kind
of father for this like kind of that
figure about his game sad that he died
yeah he was open about it okay
and he was cool and then he and we were
both Busboys you know he he couldn't get
gainful employment because he had he'd
been in jail in and out of jail a felony
yeah and I couldn't get gainful
employment I was 15 you know so it's
kind of like that you know we met no
space he has the odd couple
yeah but then we started doing drawing
testosterone and we pull over a few
years old doing testosterone I pull over
on the side of the interstate and
shooter in each other's butt cheeks damn
he never tried nothing sorry they never
even touch my butt weird or anything man
Wow really he would inject you with the
testosterone yeah I mean I was afraid to
do it yeah once a week I don't remember
what it was you know we just did a cycle
of it was probably he was probably
grooming you he's like kid turns 18 oh
no I think yeah I mean I'm one but I
mean you know yeah you cheat if somebody
underage yeah I mean no but I don't
think he was trying I don't think he was
doing that I never felt that it's the
sounds trying to take care of that sound
that common you know
steroids secret yeah and he just uh yeah
he was a good dude man he was he was
probably like the first yeah he's just
like a good friend man I know it sounds
crazy like you know but I think
I think he dated uh you know I think I
might have he told me got dates he went
on and you know so I don't think it
was trauma you didn't girls and
yeah yeah yeah was dating girls yeah he
would come he would like he we throw pay
my brother would throw parties because
both of them were partying and stuff so
they would throw parties and I'd have
big parties Oh get this dude in our
neighborhood girl never named her be
though wear these heels do that his own
family made him and they were like three
maybe four maybe four inches high right
full shoe he'll do six months and then
he would comb his hair straight up so he
was like a small person just a book
ended between just things God didn't
give him you know why would he do old
was he he might have been anywhere we
were kids do get him anywhere from
twenty to forty you know don't do that
did he was rock your height man he
couldn't and his grandparents were tall
were little and they and that's
what happens you know you can't yeah you
get them shitty genetics Oh
his grandmother I don't even know she
might have been three and a half that's
all she's busted she wasn't a little
person either she was like a little
person but but like with gigantism you
know talking about every little person
just rocking that cusp like they
go through it like do the big little
person yeah where they don't have that
fat ass yes normal just really small
yeah yeah yeah like not a real little
person
yeah but little people it would be like
fat asses they do pH fat not like no
yeah muscled we have this deaf kid in
our town I'll tell you this cuz I lived
in the pretty much in the deaf belt did
growing up the deaf boat they had a lot
of death by us because they had a couple
of hearing impaired schools by us and
and so you get a lot of extra deaf in
the area you know and it's why when you
have a lot of deaf people around because
you don't know if somebody's up
or if they're deaf mm-hmm you know so
you're driving by or if they're being
rude you know so you have to be careful
I remember one time they they had a deaf
kid that moved in right two doors down
from us handsome kid to think he could
have been Italian could have been kind
of Creole yeah but some kids beat him up
they thought he's doing bad magic you
know cuz he's doing all this stuff with
his hands
yeah cuz he wouldn't have a now yeah he
was doing all of this you know you gotta
be careful that bad magic ship yeah you
cuz he kept doing all those hand signals
you know but no quarters no doves they
thought he's doing bad magic and they
beat his ass so that's the kind
of stuff that I don't like in the world
man when people are you know just not
trying to be a little more patient with
each other know the world's up
right I think that sometimes I got drove
past Tiffany Lanes bowling alley
yesterday on highway 190 and I lost my
virginity back there you know yeah who's
the young lady woman it was a girl
how old yeah we were both children and
that's legal how old were Ana I was
probably 17 and people were throwing
rocks at us the whole time we're
what
yeah middle-eastern I don't know why but
if you never saw a duck
hot and yeah but whatever it takes a bus
whatever it takes
she took she took a piece of shale of a
neck that I thought might be a limestone
hickey so you just powered through it I
had to man I was young and all I wanted
to do was man at that point it's I
feel like semen is just hiding under
your skin ready to get out anyway you
have to get it out like yeah you break
your arm and just come all over the yes
you know like any like anything
somebody sneeze you'd have a ski
tow but so they're just on rocks are you
ain't you rock people were excited you
know and that's how they celebrate some
of these kids always said get in there
no matter what you were doing yeah dude
in there they could be like dropping
somebody at a funeral in town into the
grave he would always say that and he
would recite some like ac/dc lyrics
every now and then he had a mental and
he had a mental condition
yeah and uh and so that boy would go off
and he was there for when you lost your
virginity
well he was yeah people always bring him
in the be like oh let's get get in
there they called him get in there yeah
if I put him in the back you
so they'd be basketball games it's great
you know
yeah when you trying to and hide
from a shale storm you know
not these disdain age there's no one who
has like they as grown man has
catchphrases but when you're a kid there
was yeah when you were kids or was
catchphrases they used to do this thing
in my neighborhood like iam mad that
people ever do that but you know what if
you were mad right say if you were upset
about so yeah people could tell you're
upset they would be like this yeah man
oh no not there's something about it it
makes you so much matter so when you're
like I said they go yo you man well
right up in your face if like iam mad it
makes you so much matter the I love not
when you are kidding you're mad you're
kidding you're mad dude and somebody's
like yeah man I can throw it burnt it's
like somebody taking the top of your
spine and just starting it I feel like
it'd be cool that did use protection
when this young lady know will use
protection
I don't really gets going away more we
used to do dude now they had a buddy of
mine this guy Billy conforto and he was
homosexual and we were Busboys he was a
bus man he looked like don flamenco from
Mike Tyson's punch-out member yeah
without the rows yeah yeah the guy who
was like a waiter during the day yeah
that chin man
we're out here describing this during an
American bro he used to be so on it dude
no the guy that held Don's flamenco if
you split Don and
there yeah Russian guy no you're not
Russian bro wasn't he friend he's French
my buddy looked just like him exactly
like my buddy was Sox Nick nobody did he
preferred but he was also a boxer
dude he would fight he would bro he
could I mean he would fight you in and
you after if you wanted to he's up
to you guys
but he was a tough at Ewing he was a
busboy at this place because they
wouldn't let him be a waiter because the
guy who worked there some was had some
issues he didn't want gay waiter that
list though this is distracting dude no
he was a fighter he was probably the
toughest dude I know which was crazy
because you know this was a time you
know when they didn't have as many tough
game in you know now you got all kind of
tough game in you got better watching
Peter WWE
yeah dude oh yeah I'm sure you got some
NFL dudes oh you got the Indianapolis
Colts oh yeah you know some Browns oh
yeah you got some guys were uh but this
was when and Billy uh and Billy conforto
when he died he had a bunch of pills and
drove into an embankment but was that on
purpose or is that kind of party I don't
know but I will say this man whenever we
were kids he we used to do steroids on
the side of the interstate we pull off
the side of the interstate and just
shoot each other nice to do it because
there's nowhere else in the world to do
it will do but nobody's thinking oh
those two guys along the side of the
interstate they just think oh the cars
broken oh that's exactly what I think I
think those two are injecting D ball in
their ass and suck you don't think about
that you should think I would think
about a million other things before I
would think about I see you with that
looks like a French I would
assume you guys are injecting sucking
winstrol and sucking each other's great
you look like you work in a gay
construction look like you sell
two-by-four skins just inject each other
and then be like everybody else is like
I'm getting a sex changing like Nam is
gonna power I'm gonna I'm gonna
earn it bro your dick Cena hiding your
body and you're gonna be sitting down to
pee for the rest of your life soon if
you don't start taking care of yourself
I do I'm trying man so we pull off and
we'd spend time like that we would do
draw we would do uppers you know
muscular uppers and then we would hit
the we would hit the you know the gym
and everything and we all he also sold
weed so I used to drive him across to
New Orleans and he'd pick up like eight
pounds that we do
an awesome dude and the others demons
though huh yeah he had his demons man he
I think he was like abused or something
he was growing up and he used to fight
dogs too he would fight pit bulls and
Rottweilers Wow what was his issue with
them he was just I think this is a time
when you know people like we're still
like you know probably treated gay
people strangely or something and so he
didn't know never from a Rottweiler
though but he so he's like I'm gonna do
whatever I can to be tough and dude he
people with and he would knock him out
by he was the toughest he's a badass
who's bad ass pride he's a busboy so
we're out there slinging butters and
huff and whipped cream in the
freezer hey I'm getting loose getting
loose what do you mean working hard
brave it a busboy well yeah this boy was
standing at the the mentally handicapped
kid in our neighborhood he lived down at
the end of the street he would just do
ac/dc lyrics you know he just over and
over yeah yeah he just you'd be on his
porch like this but I'm not bad though
I'd rather I'd prefer that than him like
rocking out some no you know he
was growing up they had this dude you
could go watch him not really jerk off
but you could watch him kind of feel
himself in this video store and he was a
older gentleman he was older to us we
were children everybody was but he was
um they had like these wild western
doors at this place called Pat's video
and they sold shrimp too right so the
place is trying to have videos yeah
dream oh I agree
you get bloodsport it's exactly
what we get right you would only a
couple movies out then it was all Jean
Claude Van Damme
do they have cyborgs um I don't know
what the head side oh wait I don't know
what that was all right there's a little
bit before Double Impact yep they're a
double impact at American Ninja Warrior
I mean they only had like six movies
then outside of that - shrimp but then
in the back had these two wild western
doors and 21 and up oh yeah and we'd
sneak over there sometimes and they
always have this dude in there mr.
earnest who lived in our town right and
he later on we learned that he was a
mentally handicapped but he was yeah I
mean I don't think he wasn't like Dick
handicapped he was just mentally yeah
but
Wanda bus nuts and work at the video
store yeah he wasn't working there
though he was just humming out back
there he was working for himself oh this
got weird
yeah oh so you just hang out in that 21
and up video yeah he was legally could
be in there so to him it was like all
this yeah I can be in it was his
Starbucks
yes but he had a bike a bicycle that had
a baby seat on the back you know cuz um
somebody giving him a woman's bicycle
and back in the day now you pull your
kid in this little carriage and all this
he's in a safety cage with
these roll bars hell yeah when I was
young he was buckled in with one
buckle maybe an elastic see no
sides yeah no helmet this before helmets
dude or if you got hit by something your
dad was in a wheelchair forever
no back in this wish it was
legitimate yeah dude has dads with
a bike helmet on much rather
have a dad that's mentally handicapped
from an accident locally then dad who
and then ever see my father in a
bike helmet you can tell your
dad that come get it dad oh there's
nothing my dad put pegs on on his bike
and me my brother would stand that's way
dangerous pegs on oh yeah I was
dangerous dude this girl Chrissy hunt my
neighborhood lost her second toe to
those uh standing on that
barefoot that was her issue and in that
second toe and I'm gonna how you get the
second toe good do something the other
ones aren't doing it was longer yeah oh
that's what it is the same totally it's
kind like your middle finger it's always
longer than the other one so that second
toe the Raptor claw I can see how she
got cutting that spoke there is that
what happened it is and it ripped it off
or if did off dude it was out and about
it pulled it enough anyway I guess they
couldn't fix it you know this is just
that well it's a bad one to lose you
wanna lose anyone lose your pinky
Louisiana hell yeah I got spanked I lost
my key I'll tell you this dude Lawton
he said he one of his teeth was in front
of the other one directly in front of it
brah you know I'm saying he had that
he was running that 2-5 defense
in his mouth you know that front I
formation is a fullback in the front oh
yeah I know the party in the back
the wish man he said and I remember
people would ask him what I have missed
you thing he said he swung that paddle
so hard that his teeth it did
shook his whole face up and
knocked his teeth in front of each other
but that dude spanked me one time in his
office and when you came back from the
principal it was up but it was
also people were like damn bro you got
some respect he got some respect kind of
embarrassing huh it was embarrassing but
there was a level of respect with it
because you you made it through it yeah
like damn I do can get paddled I and it
made you see I don't want to get paddled
no I'm gonna keep my together work
now imagine there's no discipline in
schools what's gonna happen to you
nothing think about that nothing is
gonna happen
well we still expect our teachers to
give a when these kids are
running around start hitting - I'm not
saying started hitting him and I I don't
think and discipline without hitting him
yeah and you can also diss women I'll be
a molest a dude we had a great
discipline or lawton McKee a great man
he was a family man and he spanked kids
when they molested kid he didn't molest
anybody dude I just assume in Louisiana
molesting kids no bro you're from
Colorado ginam much easier it is to
molest a kid at high out and
undernourished with you how easiest to
molest a kid in Louisiana and that's
thick moisture air your hand close to
them they're so thick not the time your
hand gets close cuz you're lame it on
alligators down there I know you guys do
it bro no an alligator touch this kid's
dick nobody's believing that an
alligator would bite that thing right
off slap it with its tail bro fish suck
kids off I know most of our catfish
these are from Vietnam dude a lot of our
market is going abroad another race
let's leave everywhere fall asleep
indoors outdoors fell asleep I fallen
asleep some really good place did you
have those friends when you'd fall
asleep they'd with you I hate that
I draw on your face a dick no we
didn't have any of that day all pictures
dicks in your mouth
are you sleeping here our Vice Principal
Raleigh Coleman it was an urban
gentleman who had a um a ie jheri curl
he could've been black he was dark
Jerry kerbin gentleman he used to sleep
in the trunk of his car at
recess dude he got sneak over about a
teacher parking lot
just cuz you don't wanna see him yep and
he would tie off his trunk with a little
rope so it was about three inches high
he was getting look at that dark you
know it'd be hot yeah in Louisiana I
don't know why he liked it but I think
he just felt comfort in there somehow
you know I didn't have a parent I don't
know what some of his issues a jheri
curl would explain a little bit but
curled up boy Raleigh you don't see a
lot of Jay curls this day and age and I
asked somebody that if they would come
back and some guy got a dude in our
neighborhood they didn't have any arms
and always tried to with fight
people by head-butting huh you'd head
but he kicked hold up let me guess you'd
kick like an ostrich
hmm oh he could kick crazy dude
fingers yeah he had up and there this
other kid in our town a deaf kid this
deaf kid with a overbite
bruh
and that dude would just he'd
suck the blood I did neck if he got
close enough to yeah yeah we cheer for
them but this dude Clint was his name
like Clint but with an N in it as dude
had no arms dude and he but he could
literally get you on the ground
and choke you out with his
shoulder you just apply that pressure
crazy bro I mean he would just be on two
legs with that shoulder pointed right at
your esophagus
do you ever have any kids with whose
violent or mentally handed ribes license
that was a crazy party remember that
what he drive with his eyes I don't know
what the he was doing but he had a
legal driver's license how the did
that happen no arms one driver's license
killing it not fair
probably work and rubra no I doubt it
division tips
he's probably in prison dude I remember
he uh he did some bad stuff dude this
kid used to poop in his yard maybe bury
it when I was growing up this boy Mary
over Fino no rafi no shots of Mary why
did Mary exhale passed away drove in her
he actually drove a boat into an
embankment and damn drugs again it was
drugs I think drugs and alcohol wait so
he would poo into and say hey chill out
you on the yard and like y'all do
come buried in his yard make me hide it
make me why would you who's he older he
was older and was he dropping logs I
don't remember that much about the
actual poops but it was he was more he
was just older and I felt like you know
to hang out I had to cover shoot was
that a fetish of his was he like I don't
know he was not able to communicate
about his thoughts or feelings and
sawdust remember he'd I'd bury it
and that was a lot of our French that
was the relationship you didn't play
like cars or video games just play this
game I mean I think we did other
stuff but he was like always kind of
like he was like loud and I was
aggressive I was passive
you know had a shovel and that
was it that was a relationship all right
I probably buried 200 that man's poop
yard wow it's a lot of poop in a jar
though so never really disintegrates it
gets not in a jar
no jar why would you put it on the
ground see is yard and you would go
and bury it but he died though huh
passing away a lot of your old friends
and aquaintenances died yeah I think
people that end up doing drugs and you
know driving machinery at high speeds
don't it's the odds or a guess doesn't
mix at a certain point when you think
about it name anybody uses a lot of
drugs and drives at top speed who's
still alive
mm-hmm I can't only know two and both of
them died but because we well I think
the odds are so many where people get
away with it we just hear about the ones
who get caught yeah we had a boy died on
this can I grew up with him action we
could drink at the Ramada in our town
and he the Ramada Inn and uh this was in
Louisiana and coming to Louisiana and
I've even talked about that so much oh
boy Derry was his name Derry yeah and he
uh he used to put people in that hard
scarf he called it the hard
scarf dude he had this in the
headlock bro and you had to have
somebody help you get out of it you
almost had to get two black kids helping
you help you hear that good Oh bro when
he put you in that headlock that
hard scarf boy yes it was a hurt yeah I
mean he would kill you if he if you
didn't get a couple of brothers come
over and help you out of it he'd
kill you you ever had a man choke you
out with his tits uh-uh
but I had that boy clinch chose me out a
couple times with this shoulder
and I guess I don't that's a rib or
whatever there's a high
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]